he talks about the history about how the
Bible Administration
I'm initiated this is uh the censorship
uh push
Blitzkrieg and a I was the first one
that they ordered censored oh the Bible
Administration came into office on
January 21st
2021 on January 23rd they contacted
Facebook the White House contact
Facebook and asked them to start to
remove me
bizarre because even now when they've
been so frequently exposed for the
censorship your interview with my friend
Jordan Peterson from about two weeks ago
was taken down on YouTube and then they
put it up on Rumble and now you're on
Rumble and they're not censoring anybody
but what do you think about so what
would you do so so if you were president
of the United States what would you do
in terms of big Tech is it is it
breaking them up is it regulating them
how do you connect that to what you just
described with the Legacy Media that's
offering you know that's usually pushing
the pressure on big Tech to do these
things and then of course the
connections we now know with the CIA and
FBI and everything else
yeah well more and more you know we're
beginning to understand and this you
know the judicial decision this week by
judge Dougie and um you know in the
Missouri and Louisiana
uh attorney general's case is
um I think really lays it out at um
that the social media sites were kind of
victims as well
of of the censorship because
they were and I was you know I'm in
judged the the decision is 155 pages and
it's a decision that forbids the Biden
White House
I'm having any contact with social media
sites it's this extraordinary injunction
and it's I think it's bulletproof I
think that's why he did this you know
155-page decision because he wanted to
lay out the evidence
and he talks about the history about how
the pine Administration
um initiated this is uh the censorship
uh push
Blitzkrieg
um and a I was the first one
that they ordered censored
oh the blind Administration came into
office on January 21st
2021 on January 23rd they contacted
Facebook the White House contact
Facebook and asked them to start to
remove me and then three weeks later
there was a battle
the the people in the White House were
threatening Facebook
withdrawal of their section 230 immunity
which is existential threat to them
section 230 of course is a the liability
Shield
so that you know if you defamed uh you
know Donald Trump on Facebook and said
something that was untrue that you knew
to be untrue that was scurrilous and
very damaging
he can sue you but he can't sue Facebook
and Facebook is and is supposed to be a
neutral platform and it cannot be sued
and that's called section 230.
Mark Zuckerberg said if we lose that
it's existential we cease to exist and
so they would actually have to censor
more in that case because they would
have more liability so they'd be
basically censoring everybody well yeah
I mean they would need to read every
they would have to have lawyers read
every single post
and it says it for you know for
defamation there would be no way to do
it it would just collapse so
um so and that's what the White House
was threatening if you don't censor
these guys we're gonna withdraw your
section 230 immunity so
the White House was strong arming them
in the most powerful way a two sensor
and then the White House invited in all
of these agencies the really weird
agencies like the Census Bureau I mean
the CIA was involved the FBI was
involved
the th had the Department of Homeland
Security was involved
but also like the IRS and uh and the
Census Bureau and a whole bunch of other
agencies were all involved in
identifying people that needed to be
censored and the things they were
censoring were really crazy
you know it was the same thing that TNI
was censoring like 100 Biden's laptop
you weren't allowed to talk about that
anything to do with the Wuhan lab you
couldn't talk about
um but also personal attacks on the
president there was a parody of the
president and his wife
um that uh that they ordered taken down
so this is you know really this is like
King George the third you know back back
in the revolution there's the reason we
had the Revolution was that and put the
first amendment in place so that the
king or the you know ruler could not
silence critics because of government
can silence as critics it's it has
license for any atrocity
so so what would your policy be would it
be that you'd break up some of these
companies or would it be that you'd be
regulating them or let them collapse
what I
um first of all on day one I'm gonna I'm
gonna issue executive orders forbidden
for bidding uh any uh Federal agency
from engaging in the censorship
activities or recommendations or
contacts with these companies regarding
posts that they don't like
there's of course things that should be
removed from the internet you know but
they're they're it's unprotected speech
you know pedophilia and uh um and you
know uh inciting violence and you know
those kind of things you you can censor
without not violating the First
Amendment because they're not we're
friends they're illegal
yeah they're illegal and they're not
protected by the First Amendment
but otherwise I'm going to order them
all not only am I going to order them to
stop censoring
but I'm gonna basically with you know
reinstate the Smith month month act
which has been effectively just
forgotten about and abandoned that
forbids
um the federal agencies from
propagandizing American people
and that's is just as frightening what's
happening now with the you know active
propaganda by the CIA through all of
these legitimate media sites
um of our you know of debates about the
Ukraine war and about things that
Americans should not be propagandized
about you know we should we should know
who you know I think everybody should be
able to talk about these things but we
should know who it is talking
we shouldn't have the CIA running
reporters and rolling stone and uh daily
calls and Daily Beast and telling us you
know pretending that they're neutral
reporters if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell